thanks for having me it's a pleasure to
be here this is actually my first time
at Stanford somehow this is the first
time so it's it's a pleasure to see the
campus I look forward to talking today
so with that let's talk about control in
robotics a little bit the focus of the
talk will be safety critical control
you'll see this message come up time and
time again and before talking though I
really want to spend one minute just
thinking my students obviously they're
the ones that made this talk really
happened not me and all the
collaborators I have that's just a
partial list I work with a bunch of
amazing people that help bring these
ideas together so with that right and
you try and try and try it again to get
something to work this is an outtake of
us trying to get running on in this case
it's a play on a robot so as you can see
you can fall forward and back but not
side-to-side and we tried this for nine
months again and again and again and
again until it just fell apart on us
right and after nine months what
happened nine months we got this we
finally got the running it came together
and it looks beautiful right so
everybody that does it grow or whatever
knows this is the Ifrit video right that
little segment when everything's just
finally going just the way it should but
the lesson here is not so much that we
got this final video that worked then it
ran that that everything checked out
okay it's what it took to get it to work
it turns out that the secret sauce the
magic was not just trying for nine
months to turn a bunch of games but
actually going back to the drawing board
coming in and talking to my students and
say looks and we're missing something I
always say nature tells you the right
answer that tells you when you're doing
things right it also tells you when
you're doing things wrong what we're
missing was some math turns out that the
math we were doing wasn't quite enough
we had to introduce a notion of input
the state stability and once we did that
it worked in like three days after just
a couple runs
we got running so the lesson here is not
so much do a bunch of you know tuning
and then get the thing but rather let's
use math to bridge this gap let's use
math to bridge the gap between what we
understand about robotics systems and
what we actually see experimentally and
that's really the major under
pinning of this talk that's a major
underpinning of my research is how do we
understand this gap I want to do
something where I do some math where we
prove that something will happen we
check it in Tsim we put it on hardware
and it works the first time every time
what will it take to make that happen so
with that being said I'm going to talk
about a bunch of applications of these
ideas as you can imagine as marco
pointed out bipedal robots and legged
robots are kind of the bread and butter
of my lab for a long long time they
provide great examples of systems where
success and failure is this wonderful
binary any of their walks or falls on
its face we're also going to talk about
safety critical control though on a
variety different robotic systems and
finally the applications of these ideas
to robotic assistive devices so to me
this is really the place where we can
take our knowledge and actually push it
to an application domain that can help
people ideally restore mobility so with
that being said I'm going to start with
a little bit of math because I'm bound
to by law that's Caltech law where I
have to have at least a couple theorems
in my talk otherwise they just eject me
from the faculty and so to begin with
we're going to talk about control the OP
and all functions so this idea is really
simple people that have taken nonlinear
control will find this very very easy
but if you haven't taken any nonlinear
control I think the ideas themselves are
very approachable so back in 1892 Leo
Pandolf came up with this idea looking
at the energy function associated with
mechanical systems in the 1980s some tog
took these ideas to control systems but
the idea is really the same you have
first we have full nonlinear dynamics we
have n dimensional nonlinear system I'm
going to assume it's an affine form and
for this system we consider a Lyapunov
function in this case only a pentile
function candidate and the idea is
really simple it's basically a bowl just
like this picture indicates and if you
have a function that looks like a bowl
that goes from RN to R and and has this
nice positive definite structure the
main idea is that if you when you
differentiate this function along
solutions of the system it's derivative
points in the downward direction if
you'd like or specifically the
derivative of this function looks like a
stable linear system then you're
necessarily going to have convergence of
that function to zero if that function
converges to zero then your state will
converge to zero hence you
stabilize your system so long story
short certifying the stability of an
n-dimensional system amounts to just
checking the derivative of this function
and making sure it satisfies these
properties so the way I like to think
about this is who's ever seen these fair
games right where you put a coin in okay
so this is actually a Minnesota State
Fair where I'm from I took this video
myself I then made my wife stand in
front of this and take pictures with me
and she didn't love that but she did it
and the idea is this is Li op and all
function in nutshell right as long as
things are heading downwards you and you
know they'll ultimately end up in the
bottom so mathematically what does this
mean mathematically that this means if
we can find an input to our system and
control input such that the derivative
does the right thing then any policy
that makes the derivative do the right
thing that makes this VD crease will be
guaranteed to exponentially stabilize
your system to zero so once you
understand this basic idea that all you
need to do is find a function V this
satisfies this condition you can
synthesize controllers okay in
particular one way to do this would be
as a quadratic program where now you
just say given my input find any input
that satisfies this subject to any cost
I want it turns out that this is
Lipschitz continuous controller under
the right conditions and in fact has a
closed form solution it's a quadratic
program because as you see up there in
the math the input is f-fine in this
inequality constraint so we're just
checking a quadratic program which as
you know is a convex problem which can
be solved at the kilohertz level so this
basic mathematical framework gives us a
theorem and and I'm not gonna do theorem
itself is not so important I want you to
just have a block that there's a theorem
there and this theorem says for example
that we have stable robotic walking so
this is this theorem instantiated on
multiple robots there's a lot of stuff
under the hood here the references are
throughout the talk these were actually
the first couple generations of robots I
worked on these were custom-built in my
lab back in the day they're they're a
little simple by today's standards but
at the time it was really awesome to see
the theorem realized this is Atreus
built by Jonathan Herst at OSU this is
actually the precursor to Cassie which
I'll show later and so this theorem
really works of course the one problem
with what I just told you is that this
theorem works but the computational
instantiation of this
is actually really hard you have to
check all these conditions you have to
synthesize this Lyapunov function so the
other important point with with all this
math that I showed you is the
algorithmic side so with all this math
we have to write it in the end as an
algorithm and so one of my students who
is now at Ohio State came up with this
Frost toolbox so what this does is takes
all these theorems all this math and
Stan she eighths it as a as a in
particular two nonlinear constrained
optimization problem we use collocation
methods etc so in about five minutes we
can go from the math to the robot and
this video on the right is the results
of this optimization problems put on the
robot fairly cleanly meaning there isn't
a lot of hacking happening here really
we're taking the trajectories from the
optimization problem and popping them on
the robot so this is the third one we
start with this idea of Lyapunov
functions we get to a theorem we write
it as algorithms and ultimately we
realize it on hardware and once you have
that loop because it's very general you
can start to apply it to a whole bunch
of different robotic systems so another
example this is Duras again but now this
is Duras doing multi contact walking so
I didn't talk about it but under the
hood of all these things is a hybrid
system model if you know hybrid systems
that means we have four different
discrete domains for this walking model
we have correspondingly op and all
functions on all these domains and the
important part here is that first we're
doing this natural heel-toe contact so
we're able to instantiate this
human-like walking the second important
point is that Duras if you didn't notice
yet has Springs at its ankles so it's
naturally has passive dynamics that we
have to leverage to achieve this
locomotion this is one of the most
efficient examples of robotic walking
ever realized and the reason is in my
opinion because we're leveraging the not
inherent nonlinear dynamics of the
system to achieve the walking so I still
love this video that's a couple years
old now but I didn't still think it's
awesome the other thing to note of
course is that this was done by two
graduate students one being a young in
the back over just a short period of
time so that's the other thing is we
have to deal with less resources and
let's say Boston Dynamics but we can do
it with the right math so we can apply
this to other domains too though because
it's math its general so this is
actually a really recent result now
where we take the same ideas that is
with this method of generating gates in
formal controllers for for bipedal
robots and
why it's a quadrupeds in the case of a
quadruped ed we just view the quadruped
ed as two bipeds that are connected by
reaction forces at the at the torso so
basically it's two walking robots that
are kind of holding hands through the
torso right and the interesting thing is
because of the quadruped ed structure we
can generate gates for quadrupeds in
about three seconds that's three seconds
from pressing the Go button to realize
it in on hardware using the full
nonlinear dynamics of the system that is
there's L reduced order models here this
is just straight full order dynamic
models so this shows again the
extensibility of the theory to do
interesting things of course the great
thing about quadrupeds is they're really
robust especially when compared to
bipeds so this is us taking the Quadra
pet on this root system right outside my
office at Caltech you'll actually notice
it gets a little airtime right about
here there it goes
so the other thing is I was actually
shooting this video and after it did
this it turned direction and we weren't
controlling this direction it just
started coming right at me so I was kind
of for a moment wondered whether this
was the moment that robots take over the
world and and then I realized there's no
ml on this robot so I'm probably safe I
know but the point is that we can apply
this to a bunch of different domains so
the final bit of course in this light is
that the same ideas apply to different
bipedal robots so this is Cassie this is
built by agility robotics and the same
theorem applies it doesn't matter that
the legs are inverted it doesn't matter
they're Springs everywhere the math is
the math and so what I'm showing first
is just so we get a really nice
agreement between the sim in reality the
great thing about Cassie is unlike Duras
as it's meant to go in more natural
terrain environments so we can take it
around the lab we can take it outside on
flat ground we could even take it
outside on rough terrain so this is a
single gate that we generated with a
single controller doing all of these
things and just showing the robustness
of it so there's no hacking to handle
the terrain versus this environment
versus this environment so the goal here
again is to demonstrate that the math is
reasonably extensible okay but even with
robustness and reasonable extensibility
it has its limits before talking about
that here's some jumpy because it's fun
there's no other reason
this again is the same idea that once we
know the math we can apply to a bunch of
different domains not just different
robots but different walking types so
that was jumping this is fast walking
now same controller
same framework we're getting about a
meter for a second which is pretty good
even though like I mentioned we're not
planning for this walking speed this is
just one controller running all these
different behaviors this is just for fun
okay so one more thing we're starting
now that we understand walking we can
start to think about doing more
complicated autonomous maneuvers so in
this case we're trying to walk around
this square of course a walking robot
with legs can't directly track the
square but what we can do is is use this
framework to actually understand what
trajectories are allowable around the
square and then correspondingly track
the square as place as possible so I'm
just showing that with the math comes
this repertoire of different
environments that we can approach and as
I mentioned earlier while we're robust
and while though that's awesome I need
to show that it has limits and these are
the limits same root system I showed
earlier on the quadruped head but now
for the biped it doesn't quite make it
it was really close actually just about
made it through so it's hard to tell
maybe from the video but these roots are
a good three four five inches deep at
places so this is it's non-trivial and
of course remember there's no cameras on
this robot it's not looking at the
terrain it's not perceptive it's not
doing foot placement this is just sheer
robustness of the non linear controllers
to unknown disturbances to the system so
thankfully the robot was not harmed it
actually got right back up and walked
again which was pretty cool but this
also shows the limits to what we can do
in terms of just applying theory without
thinking about the environment that
we're interacting with so that leads to
the second point of this talk the second
point of this talk is safety critical
control and in some ways the Lyapunov
stuff I talked about earlier was the set
up the Lyapunov methods been known for a
long time CLF based QPS are fairly new
and you can do a bunch of cool things
with them but it doesn't get us where we
want to be in the safety critical
control context we don't want to
necessarily stabilize every system what
we really do is want to make every
system safe and so the point is we need
something more general than lis up and
off and for this we're
introduced control barrier functions so
this is a leopa dog like extension to
safety so before doing that I want to
start with a little history because I
think history is really important
sometimes in academia we get caught up
and just talking about the paper we
published six months ago and that's all
awesome but these things go back a long
ways so it turns out this notion of
safety that I'm defining here goes back
to Nagumo in 1942 what's crazy is
Nagumo's theorem here was lost in time
at least two or three individual times I
mean it was rediscovered independently
multiple times but it traces back to him
in 1942 you can imagine this was kind of
a bad time for the world so you could
see why things were lost at this moment
so beginning with we have dynamics again
fully nonlinear dynamics no assumptions
except I'll assume they're a fine we
define a safe set our safe set now we
can argue about whether this actually
defines safety or not but for these
purposes I'm going to say safety is
staying inside a set seat that is the
set is forward invariant initial
condition in the set means the solution
stays in the set for all time okay and
in particular we're going to define our
sets as being the super level set of a
function H that is there's a function H
that map's from RN to R for which all of
its positive values to find the set so
the question is what does it mean to be
safe in this context that is stay inside
the set okay how do you check that of
course we don't have solutions of the
system so we need some sort of
derivative like condition to check it it
turns out Nagumo figured this out a long
time ago eighty years ago and the answer
for when we don't have a controller that
is we just have dynamics it's actually
really simple and intuitive as long as
the derivative of H along solutions
which is just the gradient times your
vector field is positive along the
boundary of your set you're guaranteed
that your set is forward invariant not
only are you guaranteed forward
invariance but it goes the other way
meaning these are necessary and
sufficient conditions for safety that is
set invariance okay now that's really
interesting and really fundamental and
the idea is intuitive if H is the earth
if your set C is defined by H being
positive then if along the boundary H
can only grow or stay 0 then H itself
has to stay positive right so that
that's clear that's that's clear why
that might be true now this idea was
extended
a long time after Nagumo we're talking
2004-2007 there's also some of this in
Obama's book from nine the late 90s but
the idea is let's take this notion of
safety from Nagumo and let's extend it
to the whole set and now we're going to
do this with a control system so the
idea is we had this condition on H dot B
positive
now we have a control employed so if
there exists a control input such as
this is true for all points in my set
then my set will be safe right and this
just follows from Nagumo's theorem
everyone convinced by that ok again as
long as this H dot is positive we can't
leave the set but there's a problem
what's the problem the problem is this
is way too conservative it turns out why
what do I mean by conservative because
it turns out that if you check this
condition on all points in your set what
does it mean it means every super level
set of H is also invariant that is I
show it graphically there but if you
started with H being greater than some
positive constant a H will always be
greater than that positive constant a so
if my safe set was this entire stage
then this says wherever I start I'm
gonna stay in a smaller region that's
safety but that's not what we want from
safety because safety should be I can
come all the way to the edge of the
stage without falling off right so the
question becomes how do we extend
Nagumo's theorems to the entire set and
that leads us to 2014 so not that long
ago so I was working with Jesse grizzle
and Paulo Taboada
and we came up with this idea that there
must be a nice way of extending it in
particular and this is the key point is
we need to allow H dot to actually go
negative sometimes because H dot has to
go negative so you can approach the
boundary of the set at the same time it
k keeo is so negative that you shoot
over the boundary of the set right as
you approach the boundary it must go to
zero so the idea here is let's take this
H dot condition and let's bound it below
by minus gamma this is a class k
function for those that know for those
that don't consider it a constant times
H so when you're inside your set H is
positive so your lower bounded by a
negative number so that means H dot can
actually go negative and decrease when
you're on the boundary of your set this
becomes zero and you
recover Nagumo's theorem so it turns out
that this and this is the important
point is this is necessary and
sufficient for safety meaning on the
entire set I mean if you check any point
in your set if this is satisfied it's
true if and only if you're safe
ok and I and this by the way just I
we're now in the digital age so I was
able to find the scrap of paper where we
first wrote down this condition and
that's what this is a screenshot of but
but this is the idea so what can we do
with this now so so now that I've done
the math we can do something with it ok
so if everyone believes what I just said
and you're welcome to check it out
there's a lot of math under the surface
then now we understand safety as this
simple derivative condition ok so what
we can do is just like we did with layup
and I'll check this in a quadratic
program right in this case we can take
any desired input you have to do any
desired controller this could come from
a machine learning algorithm this could
come from something you don't know you
don't trust and we can filter it through
this safety-critical controller by just
picking the u that's closest to the
existing u subject to the safety
constraint right and the end result is
first we have a nice closed form
solution if you want it so this is easy
to solve in real time and second we can
filter our inputs so that we're safe so
what you see here is a segue and what we
define as safety is a segue staying plus
or minus 15 degrees ok so on the top we
have a PD controller in both cases we
have a PD controller in the top my
student kicks it causes a PD controller
to overshoot and the segue falls on the
bottom we filter the input through the
barrier function and we stay within this
set always because of the barrier
function so that's safety in a nutshell
now everyone with this ok so well what
do we do with this I'm going to show
some applications now we made it through
the the math part but I think it's
important to understand what these
things mean and with that one more bit
of understanding that I think is very
interesting this is a trivial statement
and a trivial proof but it's actually I
don't want to say this but somewhat
profound and what I mean is the
following it turns out that the set of
all the OP and all functions sits as a
subset of the set of all barrier
functions in particular the OP and all
function
are a special case of barrier functions
when your set is a point because not
only do barrier functions keep you in
the set but they actually stabilize you
to the set outside of the set and that's
a proof of this right here so the point
is we haven't lost anything by going to
barriers we were Coverley up and off as
a special case but we've gained
something because inside these safe sets
we can move around freely but we know we
won't lead the sets okay so with that
let's see this stuff in action one of
the cool examples of this was actually
came up when I was at Georgia Tech with
Magnus Edgar stat so he if you don't
know is a multi robot system guru and we
had this idea that at the time of the
robot Aryan he had the idea of the robot
areum I should say and I was at Georgia
Tech so I'm like that's great but so the
robot areum the idea what the robot
areum was people we're gonna have this
multi robot testbed and people from
around the world can implement their
code on this testbed and it's still
going to this day you should try it it's
actually really cool but the point is
that what is the first thing people will
do when they put their code on robots
what are they gonna try to do I should
say crash the robots alright that's what
I would do let's see if we can crash the
robots so the idea is let's use barrier
functions as a safety filter as a safety
layer on the robot areum to prevent the
robots from crashing but this is the
other important point we want to do it
in a minimally evasive way that is we
want them to implement their algorithms
if their algorithms are right we don't
want to do anything but if they're wrong
we want to keep it safe so here's an
example in this case imagine the user to
the robot areum implements an algorithm
where we want this robot to go straight
of course if all the robots go straight
across the circle they're all gonna run
into each other right in the middle
right so then we filter it with a
barrier function that's a safe region
around the robots and you see they're
coming in coming in it's looking bad and
then there goes the barrier so when they
get in the barrier takes over and it's
like these little virtual force fields
around all these robots and then they
end up spinning the interesting thing
here of course is that there's no
planning happening here this is not a
centralized decision-making process that
they should tartes the spin in some
direction rather the barriers just cause
them to roll off each other until they
finally get free of each other and can
go to their ultimate destination so just
to show you it's true for different
types of robots this is the same idea
except now we have a human
controlling a drone specifically a grad
student and these four drones are all on
autopilot quote-unquote and what he's
going to do is try to crash one drone
into the other drones so this is what's
happening and the only thing preventing
them from hitting each other is the
barrier function under the surface and I
should note that this is done on the
full non-linear dynamics of the system
turns out differential flatness gives
you a nice way to synthesize these
barriers even for the full non-linear
dynamics of the drones and so you can
see that nonlinear dynamic behavior with
all these oscillations okay so a couple
more examples just to show it's not
limited to multi robot systems this is
actually a video done by my postdoc who
had never actually published a paper on
it but this is an automotive application
with lane-keeping so in particular here
you have a lane barrier function defines
the lane and this controller is keeping
the car in the lane
despite what the humans doing so you
desired as a human so you can see here
on the left is the control going to the
car on the right as a human and you'll
see these steering wheels don't align
all the time because the humans trying
to drive the car out of the lane and the
barrier function is taking over when you
get near the boundary of the lane and
keeping the car in the lane right so
this is a safety feature application
there's a lot of applications the
automotive industry in this context one
more application that's kind of
interesting is Yamaha we've been working
together a little bit especially with my
students and they want to implement safe
features on boats so it turns out this
works on boats too in this case this the
barrier function is don't hit the dock
the human is driving the boat and trying
to ram the boat into the dock and the
barrier function takes over and and
prevents the boat from doing it and the
reason I'm showing all these videos is
they're all examples of very different
dynamical systems that are being kept
safe in this context so with all that
being said a little bit of recent
research that I think is important and
interesting is everything here assumed
that we had a model of the system and
that model was correct right this is a
model based derivative so the question
becomes what about the real world what
if we don't have perfect models of the
system so in this context it ties into
learning so the idea here is don't learn
the whole dynamics don't don't
necessarily filter our learning and
rather let's take the real-world
instantiation of the system and learn
the deficits as they relate to the
barrier function so we can enforce
safety even if we don't have perfect
models so a little more concretely this
is the process and it's a very simple
straightforward application of learning
that the non-trivial part is applying it
to the barrier function specifically so
what we do is we do empirical risk
minimization as you would imagine and in
this case what we're doing is we're
looking at sort of the difference
between what h dot we would predict we
would get from the model versus the h
dot we're actually observing from the
system itself and the goal is to make
those as close as possible that is learn
this remainder term in the H dot
derivative such that everything lines up
perfectly right once we learn this we
hopefully can guarantee safety we do
this through an episodic learning
approach and this is what it looks like
on actual hardware so this is the other
important point this actually really
works on hardware this was a
demonstration done about a month ago so
on the top we have with them without
learning so without learning what
happens when you're driving the Segway
because there's uncertainty in the model
you're gonna go unsafe you leave the
safe region the learning means that
we've learned these deficit dynamics and
hence we can keep the system safe even
with us uncertainty in the system so
these are the kind of applications we're
looking at in the learning plus control
domain is take our models take our
mathematical understanding of the system
and then apply it to these very dynamic
nonlinear systems so one final note is
some other recent work we're doing is on
the MPC front and I think this is
important to note for a couple reasons
first these CLF QPS and the barrier
functions that I showed you are not MPC
they're different in in multiple
respects they're the same and that
you're solving an optimization problem
with QP the difference is these work for
the full nonlinear dynamics of the
system as is no linearization needed MPC
if you know works for the linearized
dynamics or a linear system the question
is can we bring these two together so
the advantage to the MPC is that it lets
you look out over a longer time window
the CLF QP
you can only look instantaneously so the
question is can we take that time window
and add CLF constraints to the longer
time window to get better performance so
we're starting to try to understand that
interplay and we're doing this on
hardware because that's where it really
matters so again back to
segueway we're starting to play with all
these different instantiations of cl f
QP s MPC and the combination thereof and
the hope is to understand the best way
to do optimization based control online
on these dynamic robots and the ultimate
goal of course is to handle uncertainty
in every possible way so this is a
recent video about a week ago now
actually and here we inject uncertainty
at all levels so we have uncertainty in
state estimation so that means the
Segway doesn't really know where it is
we have uncertainties in the model all
these uncertainties add up and what we
want to do is guarantee safety in this
case safety is staying within this
region and staying upright doing all
those things at the same time and if we
we properly model and handle the
uncertainty we can stay safe even when
the this system up there clearly doesn't
right so that's where that's where we're
heading on the safety side right and
what in bringing safety into the system
okay so now that we've done lis up and
off and we've done safety we show these
examples on multiple robot systems we've
covered a lot of ground already in a
short period of time there's one more
layer I want to talk about one more
important piece of the robotics world
that we need to focus on so everything
we've done so far has been on the low
level control right if your control
theorist this is this is your natural
domain right we have dynamics and we we
do things like avoid things we stabilize
things relative to a plant the question
becomes now how do we bring in other
levels of decision-making for example
and so this tie is now into autonomy so
to achieve autonomy on systems what do
you need to do you need to think not
just about the low level continuous
domain but also this discrete level
decision-making domain okay so how do we
bring these layers together so if you're
a roboticist you know typically these
things are done in the highly decoupled
way the control theories come in and it
stabilizes the system once they have a
stable system they give it to the
computer scientists the computer
scientist does a bunch of planning with
that and gets it to do more macro level
behaviors so can we bring these these
two ideas together and let me let me
start with a little motivation for doing
this on the Markov decision process
level so we started thinking about this
actually relatively recently in the
context of the Mars 2020 mission so for
this mission you're going to have a
/ and a helicopter the helicopter will
have about two minutes of flight time
the rover obviously can go basically all
day on a charge so the question is how
do you coordinate these different
robotic systems but it's not just a
coordination problem because there's a
safety component obviously you don't
want the helicopter to crash there's
also an information planning and passing
component because the helicopter will
have a lot more information at the macro
level then the rover does at this sort
of local level so how do we take and
combine all these things together so we
worked on this in the cut in the context
of Marcia Markov decision processes so
this is an experimental demonstration of
what we did so we have a rover in this
case a Segway and this is the helicopter
a drone this is a completely autonomous
demonstration meaning my students hit go
and then nothing else so what's
happening here is there each utilizing
their own capabilities in the context of
a Markov decision process to build a
better image or better representation of
the world so the rover went out it
couldn't find the sample so the
helicopter mapped the environment pass
that information back to the MDP
associated with the rover and the rover
knows where to go and ultimately can get
there with high probability so the idea
is to bring these two pieces together on
the planning side now what did I ignore
in this whole process safety so I just
spent all this time talking about
nonlinear dynamics not only to control
all these wonderful things yet I didn't
talk about safety in this demonstration
at all so it turns out that even though
that was completely autonomous and my
students hit the button and then it went
that was autonomous the hundredth time
that hit the button right every previous
time it did things like this so you can
actually see I was recording this and
then I freaked out because the drone
started going like this there's a time
delay that propagated through the system
and ended up flying into a wall and
break into a million pieces it turns out
that happens so often that my students
rebuilt the drone so that it would hit a
wall and break apart and then they could
reassemble it right there to run another
experiment so you know you're not very
robust if you plan on the thing breaking
apart in a million pieces so you can
rebuild it right they still did great
I'm not I'm not downing my students but
I'm telling you sort of the need for
safety critical behavior called other
couple examples the drone thing I showed
earlier when time delays prop
through the motion capture they would
collide right even though we're provably
safe again provably safe is provably
safe subject to the assumptions you're
making on the system right of course
you've seen the Segway fall multiple
times so this leads to our final
component at the technical level which
is doing safe autonomy so here we're
gonna do safety critical palm D piece to
understand this at a better level and
you'll see how this all connects back up
with what I've talked about earlier so
in particular we're gonna use control
barrier functions so for these palm DPS
we have these sort of probabilities that
tell you where you're gonna go at any
given time given some discrete structure
on the system and the interesting thing
is that you can write these palm DPS as
discrete time dynamical systems that
update these sort of probabilities
turns out this actually goes back to
some work by Max Weber in 2013 where
they they had these kind of formulas for
the evolution of the system my postdoc
did this work as well and the important
point is you can understand this
discrete system and its evolution at a
probability level through this discrete
time dynamical system and we can start
to reason about this discrete time
dynamical system now and safety thereof
in particular we can define barrier
functions for discrete time dynamical
systems this was also done by cow shell
for the just normal discrete-time case
calistri not that Berkley but it's a
very it's exactly what you would expect
this is a discrete time sort of
derivative subject to a class k function
in your function the point is we have
barrier functions for this discrete
evolution of the system once we have
these we can prove that in fact these
are necessary and sufficient for safety
just as I talked about earlier but now
we're again remember we're dealing at
this discrete level this probability
level for the system evolution and that
means that for this level you can make
sure your robots for example don't hit
objects in the environment because
that's what safety means at that
planning level right you can also do
more interesting things and this is
where things get really interesting
because you can start to think about
doing things like having multiple sets
where you intersect them and you union
them and so what you're doing now is
instantiating specifications the
specifications might be always stay
within a collection of sets right then
you're doing an intersection or stay
within the union of sets and for these
different
behaviors you can write this as barrier
function conditions on the palm DP or
the discrete time dynamical system
associated with the palm DP this leads
to the final point which is you can
actually instantiate a whole bunch of
specifications so this is a bunch of
temporal logic specifications and I just
highlighted the two I showed you earlier
there's a whole bunch of other
specifications you can do at this high
decision Leakey making level that is you
can formally verify that your system
satisfies these specifications and check
it through barrier functions then you
can also do what I showed you earlier
which is filter any given policy through
the barrier function to find the policy
that actually meets your specifications
even if your original policy didn't so
the lesson here is we've gone from
continuous level dynamics where I took a
control policy and I filtered it I
modified its to guarantee safety and now
we're at the discrete Penn planning
level where we can also filter a policy
so that we guarantee safety so we can do
this at multiple tiers and multiple
levels of the system and in this context
we're looking to realize this on multi
robot system specifically heterogeneous
multi robot systems so now each of these
systems might have their own barrier
functions on them for example at the
continuous level this segue does but
then they're gonna at the discrete level
use this palm DP representation to
coordinate to try to find a sample in
this case it's the Christmas present
this was filmed in December so Christmas
present so what happens is each of these
robots have their own pom DPS that's
interacting through some sort of macro
level upon DP so information and
probabilities are being passed between
all of these robots and first the most
capable locomotion robot goes out then
the next capable robot and in the end
they've mapped the environment with
reasonably high probability they know
where the obstacles are and hence they
can send the final in this case the
rover to actually go retrieve the sample
so you're bringing through autonomy on
multiple layers so we hope to actually
extend this even further because what I
did so far was sort of a a compositional
safety at discrete level planning you
could also imagine an interaction level
of safety right so this is actually a
movie that my students took we're
getting ready for a lab tour and I
walked into the lab and they were just
doing this so this is what my students
just do sometimes when they're waiting
for lab tours and so they're controlling
these robots
is not autonomous they're using
joysticks but they'd like to kind of see
how close they can get the robots which
terrifies me to be honest I'm just like
cringe and they do this cool stuff where
they're clearly sort of passing
information right by by doing this so
the question is how do we add this to
this discreet level planning where we
guarantee safety this is not guaranteed
safe that's why freaks me out but also
we can use coordination and
collaboration between robots even at a
dynamic level to make decision-making
and do interesting things so that's
where we want ahead alright so we've
taken through the math we've taken
through the theory let's get to the
final piece in the remaining minutes
what I think is really exciting so no
more heavy math we're done with that
you've now graduated to the the reward
at the end of the rainbow which is
getting to things like robotic assistive
devices that is what are the
applications of these ideas and I think
robot assistance is one really wonderful
application where we can actually make a
real impact in people's lives so
starting with this is the video I showed
earlier of humanoid robot walking now
once we make robots walk and understand
how they walk at a mathematical level
what does that imply we can hopefully
help people walk better right that's a
very straightforward thing but it turns
out it's not quite so simple from a
mathematical level but this is
essentially what we're doing in my lab
right now so first this is a prosthetic
this is the third gen prosthetic we've
built from scratch in my lab and this
prosthetic is running a quadratic
program in real time as the controller
based on control the OP and all
functions so we're able to translate the
math and the Kannamma near controllers
to the device and then also we generate
gates for the prosthetic as if it was a
humanoid robot that is we take the human
we generate a model of the human a model
the prosthetic and we generate formally
stable gates that we put on the device
itself so we're able to make that
transition from robot walking to
prosthetic and actually have it work in
the real world what I mean is these are
two of my graduate students walking
outside with the device showing their
robustness so that's one application now
the one thing about prosthetics I love
prosthetics it's a really wonderful and
compelling application but humans are
very robust at making prosthetics walk
right you don't really know how much is
the prosthetic or the human in this case
is they can walk with a peg leg right so
that leads to this
in application that's I find incredibly
compelling which is exoskeletons so this
started a couple years ago this is joint
work with Jessie grizzle at Michigan and
council Shree not that Berkeley and the
idea was if we know how to make robots
walk we can put that on exoskeletons
that hold humans make them walk
dynamically hence make people walk
dynamically even if they can't walk on
their own right and so it turns out this
theorem I was showing through the whole
talk it's from a 2014 TAC paper and it's
this theorem represented as algorithm
that's living on this device and I'm
just about to show you so it was about
four years from TAC to device now where
this is joint work I should say a lot of
joint work meaning all the mechanical
design and algorithms were done by
wonder craft a startup company in Paris
France and this is the device walking
stabili dynamically with the math under
the surface so you see the stable
periodic orbit now the important thing
is once the device can walk somebody can
get in the device and walk with it this
is a complete paraplegic he has
absolutely no function of his legs
whatsoever and hasn't for ten years and
this is as far as we know the first
example of paraplegics ever walking
without crutches with an exoskeleton as
walking dynamically with an exoskeleton
and these are three examples and there's
been over 20 people that have now walked
clinically with that with these with
this exoskeleton technology in Europe so
this to me is the ultimate application
of an idea where you can prove some math
do some that's all wonderful but in the
end has had a real impact on their lives
so it's very powerful and hence we want
to take it further we want to build on
that success so we just started what's
called the Rome's initiative at Caltech
robotic assisted mobility science
initiative and the idea is to develop
more and more advanced controllers for
exoskeletons and prosthetics using these
ideas so this is now in my lab these are
my graduate students and Megan who's
wearing the device is not a paraplegic
thankfully but we can she can wear the
device and we can test out ideas on this
device in the lab at a much faster loop
rate than we can in a clinical setting
so I'm going to show a couple examples
of that the first one I really like
because it ties together what I talked
about earlier barrier function so you
saw barrier functions I presented them
to you but here's the
let's use barrier functions for variable
assistance on exoskeletons so what we're
gonna do is so so far the results I
showed you on the exoskeletons was we
generated a stable walking gait for the
device a person got in use the device he
he or she had no impact whatsoever on
what the x-ray was doing they were
literally along for the ride and I've
written this XO it's awesome but it's
also just it just forces you to go
through right so the question is what if
the person doesn't have a complete
spinal cord injury but a partial spinal
cord injury or stroke can we give them
partial assistance variable assistance
while keeping them safe and so the idea
here is let's take tubes around these
nominal trajectories so the the green
lines you're seeing are the provably
stable trajectories that will result in
walking we take tubes around them the
tubes define your barrier functions and
what we do is by changing this gamma we
can change how aggressively we stay away
from the boundary of the tube that is we
can assist more or less depending on
what we want to do hence we can do
variable assistance so this is this
being tested with different assistance
levels in my lab Megan and Thomas are
doing the tests my graduate students and
the masks you see is Mehta is measuring
metabolic cost so what we're doing is
seeing how much work she's doing
relative to the assistance level were
offering and presumably for doing this
right for full assistance she should do
less work than for partial assistance
right because she should start to have
to do some of the work we did this on
eight subjects just to be thorough and
we did this testing
20 to 30 minutes of metabolic se and the
end result is we found exactly what we
hoped which was that in fact we're doing
variable assistance they have more input
input into the movement of the system
with the barrier functions that they
have without them so that's one
application another one is to start
bringing learning into the mix so
there's two ways you can do learning in
this context the first is actually at
the control level kind of like what I
talked about with barriers in this case
we're doing a proof-of-concept
demonstration where we take an RNN and
we learn the controller we're applying
on the device and then the RN n does all
the control on the device that is this
device as being 100% controlled by an RN
n so that shows we have the ability to
learn these complicated controllers and
instantiate them in real time where the
RN n is the one doing the
puts into the system meaning the rnns
talking to the motors right so that's at
the low-level control we can also do
learning at the high level so in this
case think about learning at the
decision-making so in this context what
we're interested in is deciding what
gate to actually put on the device so
thus far what we do is we generate all
these gates using the math I showed you
we put them on the device the person
walks with it that's it
the question is what gate would the user
prefer so it turns out you can't
mathematically figure out what gate is
best for a person or at least maybe you
can but I don't know how to do it right
the best way to ask what a person likes
best is to what ask the person okay so
that leads to preference based learning
it turns out this is a really powerful
way in that sense what we're doing is
learning the cost function of the person
by asking them their opinion and the way
you do it is is a sort of binary
decision process it turns out we can
prove mathematically has really nice
properties of convergence to learning
this cost that is do you like this Gator
this gate do you like this gate or this
gate and by doing that just like when
you get your glasses checked right it's
a binary decision a or B you can
converge in on these optimal costs you
can see the converging and after
multiple trials and this is what it
looks like in action and what you're
gonna see now is a bunch of trials where
after every trial the the human subject
says they like what they would like and
you can see the corresponding sort of
cost function you're learning updating
accordingly until we find what the
person likes the best and we can do this
both in one direction meaning changing
one variable in the system on the exo or
in multiple directions so this is an
exciting area where we start to bring
learning together with dynamics control
the dynamics and control guarantees the
properties of the system and the
learning lets you pick what you like
best of this of these properties so
that's the end end conversation I I went
through a lot of stuff I went through a
lot of math I went through a lot of
robot videos but the idea is start with
the math and and that's something I
obviously firmly believe in I'm a
nonlinear control theory so that's bound
to be what I say but hopefully I've
convinced you with all the movies that
at least there's some merit to doing
math right so start with the math we did
stability and safety with Lyapunov and
barrier I talked about the extensions of
that to autonomy that there's a whole
bunch
work we're doing in my lab on that and
of course all the applications remember
the goal in the end was to bridge the
gap the question is have we bridged the
gap no we haven't we're getting better
we're getting much better but there's a
whole bunch of work to do on getting
things that work the first time every
time on robotic system so we have a lot
of work to do in that domain the one
tool I showed you though is barrier
functions
remember that Lyapunov is a special case
of barrier so this includes Lyapunov and
this tool both that the continuous to
discrete level is actually proved really
useful to better bridge this gap and
that's the subject of future work to
better understand that connection the
final point I want to make is that I
think it's our job as a roboticist to
think about the real-world applications
to what we do and to have an impact in
that domain so there's multiple ways
that we're thinking about this so I want
to just to finish the talk highlight a
couple of reasons the first is bringing
robots in the public I think this is a
service we can do that's fun for us and
that's demo robots in public settings
and we've done this a lot and these are
just some of my favorite sort of
pictures and videos of kids reacting to
robots
I just always find these to be awesome
this one was amazing we're at the DARPA
Robotics Challenge finals and this kid
just came up and said he's dancing with
the robot these kids when they see
robots walking start to march with the
robots it's interesting even though
these robots don't look like people they
definitely feel an emotional connection
to them because of their movement so in
some ways movement is life right and so
it's great to be able to tap into that
connection to get kids excited about you
know robots and math and engineering and
everything else of course there's also
applications to real worlds settings I I
don't have a company I don't want to
start a company I'm not interested in
that domain but some of my students do
so in this case one of my former PhD
students is the CTO of Mesa robotics and
we work together on hamburger flipping
it turns out that flipping a hamburger
is essentially the same as making a
robot walk right it's surprising but
true and and so you have to deal with
this friction it has to be a dynamic
maneuver
so we work together on this this was
actually deployed in in Cali burger in
Pasadena and a couple other college
burger locations so I ate a hamburger
cooked by algorithms at my lab came up
with which was really cool it's also a
badger Stadium so the point is these
things do have real-world applications
of course the real-world application and
the most excited about right now is the
clinical one and again this is only
possible because we're working with a
company that does clinical testing I
don't I don't have the capability to do
that in my lab but we could these are
images that I didn't show earlier but
these are a bunch of patients testing
the exoskeleton and looking at its
behavior and the great thing is we can
start to look at what they think about
using the device and we can make
decisions based on that so it's about
closing that loop and starting to
generate better and better controllers
that we ultimately deploy in a clinical
setting so the final thing I want to
note out of these videos that's really
powerful is that these are clinicians
running the device not engineers so
that's a whole nother level of
transition is when you can have a device
that's robust enough to be clinically
deployed without engine engineers
necessarily running the device so again
that's wonder craft and that's their
engineers but it's it's great to be part
of that collaboration so with that the
message here is the following the
message is let's get robots in the real
world and let's get robots working with
people to do things that are better so
in this case this was a video where this
is just a student at Cal Tech she's not
in my lab she was sitting on the bench
and we ran Cassie up to her and she
started talking to and I thought it was
cool because this is sort of the
interaction you'd like to see among
these systems so with that thank you
very much for listening
[Applause]
yeah I saw a hand go up here yeah that's
a great idea so in this case the
discrete time dynamical you're sorry
question so the question was that these
belief space dynamics are stochastic in
nature so what modifications do we have
to make to the barrier to handle
stochastic dynamics so in this case
we're not handling the stochastic
dynamics we get a discrete time
dynamical system that updates the
probabilities so it's not a stochastic
barrier per se that being said you can
also treat things stochastically and do
deal with stochastic barrier functions
there's been a work not in my group but
other groups handling stochastic
barriers so it depends on which
perspective you want to take in our case
this is a discrete time dynamical system
updating the probabilities at every
given in a discrete-time fashion you can
again equally viewed it's view of these
evolutions sort of stochastically and
deal with stochastic barrier functions
and that's a really interesting area to
deal with as well I saw a hand go back
there first how can you come up with
barrier functions for systems like
robots where eventually you only
stabilize them right right great
question so the question was how do we
synthesize barriers
the answer is easily and hard lis at the
same time so let me let me explain a
little bit this is something I glossed
over throughout the whole talk but I
just kind of made it seem like you just
pop out a barrier for your set and then
you put on your system and the world's
wonderful place right it's not that easy
in reality so it turns out that if you
have for example what I did with the
tubes around the trajectories for the XO
is much enlight with what you had if you
longer horizons let's say you have a
walking robot you have a periodic
trajectory you want to
keep a barrier function around that
trajectory or we've also done things
like stepping-stones so we have barrier
functions for the foot placement of a
robot so you move those barriers around
you can change how the foot is being
placed on the robot so you can
synthesize those barriers actually quite
easily because it turns out the barrier
function itself defines this set as a
tube you could look at you know making
sure the norm the norm distance from
your periodic orbit is less than some
epsilon right so that part's easy the
problem is you don't know if that's set
that you're defining by H is control
invariant that is you don't know if
there exists an input that will keep you
in that set so the barrier function will
tell you the input but that input might
not be feasible so this process of
generating feasible inputs to keep a set
invariant is a very very hard problem
that I glossed over here and we're
working on that we're working on that in
a couple context I also should say that
a lot of work that's been done in the
past feeds into that for example if you
saw the hamilton-jacobi equations it'll
give you a barrier function that is
feasible with respect to inputs of
course that's not a computationally
feasible thing to do so you do run into
this issue that and I don't want to
pretend it's not there that you have
with similarly with Leo and all
functions and that synthesizing a
barrier function that's dynamically
feasible that has that means at every
point in time that QP is generated input
such that that input can be satisfied by
the actuators is a hard thing a very
hard thing and there's a whole bunch of
PhD topic sitting there for probably the
next 10 years because it ties into the
fundamental questions about dynamical
systems things like control invariant
sets okay does that answer your question
okay I saw another one yeah
into scranton for this I'll say
absolutely do you have to rely we
program or every great question great
question so the question was the
exoskeleton stuff I showed it says
general means anybody gets in this
device and walks or how do you handle it
so I didn't talk about this but it's
it's actually I'm glad you asked this
because I get to say this now is that
it's not general to every person and in
fact one of the great things is it
doesn't have to be meaning what we do is
or what wonder craft does in this case
is because and they actually build upon
frost that framework I talked about
earlier so they took Frost that package
and modified it to run really well in
this context what they do is and I've
written in the exo is you measure a
patient okay a couple key measurements
from there you can use it look at
biological textbooks and get an estimate
of their mass inertia distributions you
create a model of the patient you
intersect that with the model of the exo
you use that joint model to generate a
stable walking gait that's patient
specific that process takes a couple
minutes five minutes maybe then from
those gates they can generate like 1020
gates they try out a couple see which
one the patient likes best so it is
patient specific and customizable to a
given patient based on that process
right great question time very so so
right now no that's a great question
though so right now it actually doesn't
even really allow for prayer allows for
preferences only at a macro level at a
gate level and a couple binary choices
so what's being implemented clinically
right now is they they generate a
collection of gates they put them on the
exo the patient wears it tries one they
kind of give some high-level feedback to
the clinician they pick another gate and
then that's two or three gates and
that's it
you're stuck with what you got right so
what we're doing with the preference
based learning was in some ways trying
to mathematically quantify that process
and actually generate gates that are
really nice but what we did was not
time-based it was purely gate based at
this moment the question is could there
be a time-based component right meaning
can you rather than saying I want a
whole new gate the patient should be
able to say I want my knee to go a
little higher throughout the gate or I
want to take a little bit longer step
well that's sort of a gate level but you
see what I'm saying and that would be
awesome to add the
sort of modifications around gates in a
much more time-sensitive fashion it's a
great area we've we've not touched that
yet but that would be they'll be really
interesting to study yeah like if you
say let someone try to push it to the
wall yeah yeah yeah so so the question
was how does the device react to
conflicting barrier functions so this
goes back to the earlier point which is
barrier synthesis so if you have a
single barrier function if it's if it's
dynamically feasible meaning it's
controlling variants of controlling
variants that you're good to go
meaning if you're starting that there's
no way you're going to hit the wall
because you've verified ahead of time
that you can't hit the wall and then
ferry function enforces that if you have
multiple barrier I talked earlier about
intersection in Union turns out this
gets much more difficult you can't just
the easier way would be just add a bunch
of constraints in your QP with all your
barriers but you might go infeasible
then it might not be possible to satisfy
all at the same time right so in that
case you have to get smart either with
the synthesis by intersecting or Union e
to make sure it's become sort of min max
problem there's a whole bunch of stuff
in that light that you have to take into
account so yes that's that's a real
problem that requires careful study
there's been study done on this Jorge
Cortes and Magnus did a nice paper on
doing min max operations for
intersection and union on continuous
time barriers I talked about min max on
discrete time barriers a little bit so
there's a whole thing a whole wealth of
things to do to try to answer this
problem but yeah I don't want to imply
that you just define a bunch of errors
throw them together and your hardware
it's safe you're you're done right
life's never that easy yeah see what in
the back
and the axial sculpting videos good
questions so in the exoskeleton videos
the question was the people seem to be
swinging their arms a little more than
usual it that is true
in the sense that these were these were
a paraplegics with injuries from the
waist down so they have an upper body
torso and there and they are helping to
stabilize the device now the reason we
showed the video with the EXO walking
without a patient in it was to prove
that in fact the device can walk on its
own but that being said the human will
help to stabilize it further and right
now the device itself in the walking
while while stable could be stabilized
further made more robust and that's
something we're working on in the
control side right so they're the humans
helping with that through their dynamics
but that's what you're seeing is they
don't feel that the gait is as stable as
they'd like it so they swing their arms
to stabilize further
[Applause]